N
INDOHA QATAR WITH THE STORY.
>> TODAY THE TALIBAN CALLED ON
THE UNITED STATES NOT TONE
COURAGE THE AFGHAN PEOPLE TO
LEAVE THEIR COUNTRY THOUGH
THOUSANDS CONTINUE TO FLEE THEIR
BRUTAL RULE.
>> CHAOS OUTSIDE THE GATES OF
KABUL'S AIRPORT.
OTHER DAY OF DESPERATE CIVILIANS
TRYING TO FLEE AS THE TALIBAN
ISSUED NEW RULES FOR THE
COUNTRY.
AFGHANS WITHOUT FOREIGN
PASSPORTS WILL NO LONGER BE
PERMITTED TO GO TO THE AIRPORT.
AMERICAN TROOPS ARE SCHEDULED TO
WITHDRAW FROM AFGHANISTAN IN ONE
WEEK.
AND THE TALIBAN SAYS THE
AUGUST 31st WITHDRAWAL DATE
CANNOT BE EXTENDED.
>> WE ARE SENDING A MESSAGE TO
THE AMERICANS GOTTEN EVACUATE
THE CITIZENS BY THIS DATE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE MEANS TO
DO SO.
THEY HAVE PLANES AND THE AIRPORT
IS WITH THEM.
THEY HAVE TO TRANSFER ALL THE
FORCES AND CONTRACTORS WHO HAVE
RELATIONS WITH [INAUDIBLE]
>> IN THEIR SECRET MEETING
YESTERDAY CIA DIRECTOR WILLIAM
BURNS AND TALIBAN LEADER HELD
THE HIGHEST LEVEL FACE-TO-FACE
CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE TALIBAN
AND AMERICANS SINCE THE GROUP
TOOK CONTROL OF AFGHANISTAN.
COORDINATING THE WITHDRAWAL OF
U.S. FORCES COMES AMID NEW
WARNINGS TODAY ABOUT HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSES BY THE TALIBAN.
U.N. OFFICIAL SPOKE TO THE HUMAN
RIGHTS COUNCIL TUESDAY SAYING
SHE HAS RECEIVED CREDIBLE
REPORTS OF THINGS RANGING FROM
RESTRICTIONS TO WOMEN TO SUMMARY
EXECUTIONS.
>> THE FUNDAMENTAL RED LINE WILL
BE THE TALIBAN'S TREATMENT OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS AND RESPECT FOR
THEIR LIVES TO LIBERTY.
FREEDOM OF MOVEMENT, EDUCATION.
SELF-EXPRESSION AND EMPLOYMENT
GUIDED BY INTERNATIONAL NORMS.
>> DESPITE THESE REPORTS THE
TALIBAN WANTS COUNTRIES TO KEEP
EMBASSY OPEN IN TE'O KABUL
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE A TOUGH
SALE AMID THESE HUMAN RIGHT